FORMER DC OFFICER MICHAEL FANONE REVEALING TAPES HE
SECRETLY RECORDED.
SAYING AS I ENTERED THE CAPITOL,
I DID WHAT I ALWAYS DID WHEN I
WENT ON A RISKY OP, I HIT THE
RECORD BUTTON ON MY iPHONE AND
STUFFED IT IN MY POCKET.
HE WAS ONE OF THE OFFICERS
ATTACKED BY ONE OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, HE WAS SEVERELY
BEATEN, SUFFERED A HEART ATTACK
AS WELL AS A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY.
FIRST LET'S GET TO CNN'S WHITNEY
WILD JOINING US WITH THIS NEW
AUDIO.
TELL US ABOUT THIS.
>> WE KNEW THESE MEETINGS WERE
HAPPENING.
THERE WAS VIDEO OF HARRY DUNN,
MICHAEL FANONE AS WELL AS
SICKNICK ON THE CAPITOL THAT
DAY.
IN THEIR OWN WORDS MICHAEL
FANONE BRINGING US THOSE
LAWMAKERS.
A SECRETLY RECORDED MEETING WITH
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY SHOWS THE LENGTHS TWO
OFFICERS PROTECTING THE CAPITOL
FALSEHOODS ABOUT THE ATTACK.
>> WHAT I FOUND MOST DISTRESSING
IS THE COMMENTS MADE BY,
UNFORTUNATELY AS A LIFELONG
REPUBLICAN MYSELF, COMING FROM
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS,
SPECIFICALLY PEOPLE LIKE ANDREW
CLYDE WHO MADE STATEMENTS ABOUT
JANUARY 6th WHICH WERE -- NOT
JUST SHOCKING, BUT DISGRACEFUL.
REFERRING TO JANUARY 6th AS A
REGULAR TOUR DAY AT THE CAPITOL.
WHAT I SEE HAPPENING HERE IS I
SEE LAWMAKERS WHO DON'T BELIEVE
THAT JANUARY 6th IS POLITICALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS TO THEM.
NOBODY BUYS IT.
IT'S CRAP.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
>> --
>> Reporter: THE MEETING WAS
LEGALLY RECORDED IN JUNE 2021 BY
D.C. METROPOLITAN POLICE OFFICER
MICHAEL FANONE.
FANONE CALLS ON McCARTHY TO
DENOUNCE THE 21 REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS WHO VOTED AGAINST
GRANTING CONGRESSIONAL GOLD
MEDALS TO THOSE WHO DEFENDED THE
CAPITOL.
>> WHAT I'VE EXPERIENCED SINCE
THEN HAS BEEN HORRIFIC.
IT'S HELL ON EARTH.
I'M NOT A POLITICAL PERSON.
I DO NOT ENJOY MY TIME HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
I WOULD MUCH RAEGTER BE SITTING
AT HOME WITH MY DAUGHTERS
DRINKING A COLD BEER, BUT
INSTEAD I FEEL AN EXTENSION OF
MY SERVICE ON JANUARY 6th TO BE
UP HERE RIGHTING THIS WRONG.
>> Reporter: THE MEETING WAS
ALSO ATTENDED BY POLICE OFFICER
HARRY DUNN AND GLADYS SICKNICK.
McCARTHY TELLS HIM HE WANTS TO
SEE JUSTICE SERVED.
FANONE URGES HIM TO TAKE THE
CAPITOL ATTACK SERIOUSLY.
>> I'M ASKING YOU TO AGREE TO
TAKING THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
SERIOUSLY, APPOINTING SERIOUS
PEOPLE TO THAT COMMITTEE WHO
WILL NOT BE OBSTRUCTIONISTS AND
WHO WILL ALLOW THE INVESTIGATION
TO BE DONE.
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT -- WHEN WE
GET INVOLVED IN AN INVESTIGATION
THAT WE DON'T CARE ABOUT, WE
ASSIGN THE BIGGEST HUMPS TO
PARTI
PARTICIPATE.
>> YOU'RE AN INTELLIGENT MAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> McCARTHY APPOINTED FIVE
REPUBLICANS TO THE COMMITTEE.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
REJECTED TWO BECAUSE THEY
OBJECTED TO THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE 2020 ELECTION.
McCARTHY PULLED THE OTHER THREE.
DAYS AFTER THE MEETING McCARTHY
SAID THIS --
>> IT WOULD BE SHOCKING TO ME
FOR ANYBODY, FROM A PARTY ON THE
OTHER SIDE TO COME AND WANT TO
ACCEPT A POSITION, DEMOCRAT FOR
ME AND IT WOULD BE SHOCKING FOR
ME TO HAVE A REPUBLICAN GO TO A
SPEAKER PELOSI OF ALL PEOPLE TO
ACCEPT A COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENT.
>> Reporter: IN THE RECORDING
FANONE REMINDS McCARTHY HOW
DANGEROUS THE DAY WAS FOR
McCARTHY AND HIS STAFF.
HE ALSO BRINGS UP THE PHONE CALL
McCARTHY HAD WITH THEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP URGING HIM TO ACT, A CALL
THAT OTHER REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
SAY DEE VOL FED INTO A SHOUTING
MATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENTS
THAT DAY WERE BS.
YOU KNOW.
YOU WERE ON THE PHONE WITH HIM.
WHILE YOU WERE ON THE PHONE WITH
HIM, I WAS GETTING THE SHIT
KICKED OUT OF ME, ALMOST LOSING
MY LIFE.
THE WAY THAT HE -- THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU STEAL AN
ELECTION.
GO HOME.
I LOVE YOU.
WHAT THE [ BLEEP ] IS THAT?
THAT CAME FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES!
>> Reporter: McCARTHY DEFENDED
TRUMP AT VARIOUS POINTS IN THE
MOMENT.
>> HE WASN'T WATCHING TV --
>> HE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
>> I'M JUST TELLING YOU FROM MY
PHONE CALL, I DON'T KNOW THAT HE
DID KNOW THAT.
>> SIGNIFICANT MOMENT THERE.
BRIANNA, IT'S ONE THING -- YOU
SEE MIKE FANONE ON OUR AIR A
LOT.
IT'S ONE THING FOR SOMEONE TO
COME OUT PUBLICLY AND VOICE
THEIR OPINIONS.
WHAT FANONE DID WAS HE TOLD
THOSE PEOPLE IN THIS PRIVATE
MEETING TO THEIR FACE HOW HE
REALLY FELT.
HE HAD THE NERVE TO DO THAT
WHICH YOU DON'T ALWAYS SEE
PEOPLE DO.
HE TOOK THEM TO TASK.
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO OVER THE
LAST 18 MONTHS OR SO IS SHOW
WHERE PEOPLE ARE FLIP-FLOPPING
ON A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
MAKING IT A CORE VALUE FOR HIM
TO CALL PEOPLE OUT WHEN THEIR
NARRATIVE IS CHANGING AND HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
>> TRYING TO RIGHT A WRONG AS HE
SAID IN HIS DISCUSSION WITH
KEVIN McCARTHY.
WHITNEY, THANK YOU FOR TAKING US
THROUGH THAT.
>>> JOINING US NOW IS THE AUTHOR
OF "HOLD THE LINE, THE
INSURRECTION AND ONE COP'S
BATTLE FOR AMERICA'S SOUL" WHICH
IS OUT TOMORROW.
CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST
MICHAEL FANONE.
MIKE DEFENDED THE CAPITOL DURING
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK AND PAID
A HUGE PERSONAL PRICE FOR DOING
SO.
MIKE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US TODAY.
WE'RE LISTENING TO THESE
RECORDINGS.
YOU SOUND A LOT ON THEM LIKE YOU
DO JUST ON TV OR IN PERSON.
IT'S CERTAINLY THE SAME THING,
THE SAME GUY.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE
RESPONSE THAT YOU GOT FROM KEVIN
McCARTHY IN THAT MEETING?
>> IT WASN'T SURPRISING TO ME.
I SAW HOW HE HAD DEVIATED FROM
HIS ORIGINAL STATEMENTS
IMMEDIATELY AFTER JANUARY 6th,
TO SEIZE UPON THE POLITICS OF
THE MOMENT.
IT'S IRONIC IN THAT HE WAS -- HE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT JANUARY
6th WAS NOT POLITICIZED, BUT IN
A WAY HE'S POLITICIZED JANUARY
6th THE MOST.
IT JUST WASN'T SURPRISING.
BUT I'M GLAD I RECORDED IT.
THAT'S WHY I RECORDED IT, WAS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T EXPECT KEVIN
McCARTHY TO, NUMBER ONE, TELL
THE TRUTH; NUMBER TWO, RECOUNT
THE CONVERSATION ACCURATELY, AND
NUMBER THREE I WANTED TO SHOW
PEOPLE HOW INDIFFERENT LAWMAKERS
ARE, NOT JUST REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS, BUT ALL LAWMAKERS TO
THE ACTUAL AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
THEY ARE REPRESENTING.
>> IN THAT CONVERSATION, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU TELL
McCARTHY IS THAT SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU AND YOUR MOTHER
KNOW WHO DON'T THINK THAT WHAT
YOU EXPERIENCED HAPPENED HAVE
SAID THAT FOOTAGE FROM YOUR
BODY-WORN CAMERA, WHICH IS
HORRIFIC FOR ANYONE WHO HASN'T
SEEN IT.
IT IS HORRIFIC.
THEY THINK IT'S FAKED.
WHAT DO THEY THINK?
DO THEY THINK YOU'RE PART OF
SOME CONSPIRACY?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, RHETORIC FROM
THESE POLITICIANS COMBINED WITH
SOME OF THE ALT RIGHT OR RIGHT
WING PROPAGANDA, PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT STUFF.
THERE HAVE BEEN A WHOLE SLEW OF
CONSPIRACIES THAT HAVE KIND OF
POPPED UP ABOUT ME.
THE HARDEST THING TO ACCEPT IS
PEOPLE THAT HAVE KNOWN ME FOR IN
SOME CASES DECADES BUYING INTO A
LOT OF THAT CRAP, THE IDEA THAT
I WORK FOR THE FBI AND I'VE BEEN
A PLANT IN THE METROPOLITAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR TWO
DECADES WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT,
OR THAT I WAS SOMEHOW SPAWNED
FROM A PETRI DISH AND AM THE
LOVE CHILD OF NANCY PELOSI AND
GOD KNOWS WHO ELSE AND ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT.
>> YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP IN 2016,
RIGHT?
>> YES, MA'AM, I DID.
>> OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMEONE WHO
AT ONE POINT YOU SUPPORTED.
CERTAINLY YOU DON'T ANYMORE, AND
I KNOW YOU HAD SOME ISSUES WITH
HIM EVEN PRIOR TO JANUARY 6th.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR YOU, NOT
JUST FROM THE GENERAL PUBLIC,
BUT FROM FELLOW POLICE OFFICERS
INCLUDING ONES THAT YOU HAD
KNOWN FOR SO LONG AFTER JANUARY
6th, AFTER TESTIFYING?
>> THE CRITICISM THAT CAME FROM
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
HIT ME THE HARDEST.
IF YOU READ THROUGH THE BOOK, I
TALK ABOUT SOME CRITICISM THAT I
GOT PRETTY EARLY ON AFTER ONE OF
MY FIRST INTERVIEWS FROM A
DETECTIVE NAMED YARI BABICH WHO
ACCUSED ME OF BEING AN ATTENTION
SEEKER AND FELT THIS WAS ONLY
DONE IN MY OWN SELF-INTEREST.
I WOULDN'T WISH THIS EXPERIENCE
ON MY WORST ENEMY.
FOR PEOPLE THAT KNOW ME, THERE'S
NOT MUCH I WOULDN'T WISH ON SOME
OF MY WORST ENEMIES.
IT'S A DIFFICULT EXPERIENCE TO
NAVIGATE, PUTTING YOURSELF OUT
THERE, SUBJECTING YOURSELF TO
CRITICISM FROM NOT ONLY THOSE IN
YOUR IMMEDIATE CIRCLE, BUT
REALLY FROM EVERYONE IN THE
WORLD.
THAT'S BEEN THE HARDEST PART
ABOUT THE PROCESS IN PREPARING
THIS BOOK, IS KNOWING THAT I'M
NOW SUBJECTING MYSELF, MY CAREER
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND MY
ACTIVITIES SINCE JANUARY 6th TO
CRITIQUE BY ANYONE AND EVERYONE.